plus de 4 millions de francs pour les
enfants inadaptés un shaq qui a remis
hier à lino ventura pour le mouvement
personnage pendant plus de deux mois
vous le savez probablement ce sont des
vedettes qui ont répondu aux questions
de zappy max pour le quitte ou double de
radio monte carlo
une opération qui était soutenu par
antenne 2 et plus particulièrement par
noël mamère et l'équipe de c'est la vie
c'était beaucoup plus qu'une fête
c'était une ovation une immense vague
d'espoir qui a déferlé hier soir sur le
vieux-port de marseille
le service d'ordre a eu d'ailleurs
beaucoup de mal à contenir la foule
venue applaudir lino ventura et mireille
mathieu ce spectacle clôturer le grand
quitte ou double organisé par radio
monte carlo au profit de l'association
perce-neige pendant plus de deux mois
des personnalités telles que charles
aznavour maurice genevoix haroun tazieff
vous jean pierre elkabbach ont répondu à
des questions pièges
concernant leur domaine tous les gueules
ainsi obtenus ont été attribués à
l'association perce-neige pour
construire des centres pour enfants
handicapés à pézenas d'abord au dollar
ensuite et ce n'est pas fini
une opération au succès de laquelle a
très largement contribué l'émission
c'est la vie sur antenne 2
sheikh lino ventura ce chèque que j'ai
l'honneur de vous remettre au nom de
radio monte carlo accepte le comme le
symbole de tout ce fameux conte ses
enfants à qui vous avez consacré votre
vous 4 millions de francs pour les
handicapés ému lino ventura l'été
beaucoup ces dons venus des horizons les
plus divers industriels associations
particuliers et même enfants sont déjà
un signe il prouve qu'en france quelque
chose a commencé à bouger
il prouve qu enfin les barrières de
l'indifférence qui ont brisé tant de
personnes commencent à reculer alors à
l'heure des bilans
tout le monde souhaite poursuivre ce
genre d'action
m
amasser l'argent c'est bien
nous ne voulions surtout sensibiliser
l'opinion publique à ce problème
douloureux de l'enfance handicapée je
vais repenser et adapter sa vie il en
est un toutes les 20 minutes en france
ça les gens de l'australie et nous avons
le sentiment maintenant que la zone des
couteaux moins gradés - carlos lee dans
tout le sud de la france
tous les auditeurs savent maintenant la
dimension de ce problème il ya une chose
que je dois dire il faut prendre
conscience d'une chose nous disons
civilisé nous sommes en 1981 n'importe
quelle ville à un stade n'importe quel
village une école à l'hôpital une
pissotière et elle n'a pas une maison en
1981 peut mettre des enfants comme ça
c'est incroyable c'est qu'il va de
musique et je trouve ce geste est
merveilleux
et bravo monsieur ventura le pouvoir
partager vous même vous continuerez à
chanter pour les handicapés par exemple
avec bien sûr bien sûr contraire plaisir
si on m'appelle je réponds toujours
présent